ah yeah it's the bee sting king in the
Rat King
[Music]
you wanna start the show madness oh [ __ ]
this reminds me of the time T when I was
in fifth grade or fourth grade it could
have been four I did fourth grade two
times two because uh your mom held you
back no school was a lot harder when I
was growing up
mmm then it is now now these kids you
act like they can be whatever grade they
want you know they pick it's kinda like
the gender you'll be whatever gender ya
think I'm in ninth grade today yeah only
fourth
I'm 20 you can't deny him uh though the
lawsuit yeah I agree
but this um they had this thing if you
got in a fight with somebody at school
you had to stand in the hallway and you
had to put your arms on each other's
shoulders like that and you had to hug
each other for the rest of the day in
the hallway so you had to like it wasn't
like a full hug but it was like you had
to put your hands on each other's
shoulders and stand there in the hole so
when the other kids would go out between
class they would see you and this kid
you fought like right there had this
isn't a legit school yeah I get did your
mom running no this is a legit school
just a real principal Lawton McKee was
the principal McKee would make the kids
touch each other for the whole day yeah
not touch each other
that's uh that's creepy bro either way
touching each other staring into each
other's eyes for the entire day but then
the thing was you became friends with
the person that you were so it's like
arrabal idea this is the guy the kid
that beat me up you know or I actually
beat him I bad thing no I don't you got
beat up that's fine I mean I could have
got beaten up or I could have I don't
remember what was going on and but yeah
we had to hug for the rest of the day I
know you guys you guys were friends and
they were friends after she went through
that journey together oh yeah yeah I was
like dang yeah cuz you kind of had to
face it like it was like man now he
knows like you had to get to know each
other you're right different you could
only look away for so the same thing in
detention like whenever we be in
detention even if you fought the other
kid who you stole something you're
you're going through that together just
like you had no one to talk to talk to
you so you look over like so that's what
we're doing right now
yeah I feel like I'm yeah having a hang
out with ya force to him
but then we're going through this
together well yeah we are I guess I
don't want to admit it but yes I will
admit that we're going through this life
together okay calm and don't laugh like
that you laugh like uh like somebody's
you know just like molesting a hyena you
know I feel like something's wrong with
you
but listen I you know yeah look with
that bro so let's kick off uh freaking
rip my drift let's do this
and somebody said rip some a crib they
sent him a mic and bring her yeah okay
that's a little dicey yeah I'm not doing
I'm not trying to yeah good shot
ripped my crib and uh and then
somebody's hitting a crippled friend of
theirs
see that's where it gets confusing yeah
yeah and it was like I'm not you know
that guy seemed like a nice guy the
wheelchair was busted but whatever yeah
first up Theo von god damn bro you know
you're coming on the show and you wear a
freaking Curious George sweatshirt yeah
does anything have this fresh wet gender
haircut you're doing I don't know what's
going on there your sweatshirt is a very
stylish car he looked like a third grade
substitute teacher yeah and third grade
is a very popular grade yeah and you
look like the guy who came out to LA to
make an acting and ran out of lunch
money and sucks on his mom's titties for
breast milk
yeah that's not a real person that
you're talking yeah it is you bro
weed a dress like that it's super sus
and this is a Christmas gift you freak
terrible Guinea and Earth all yeah new
throws is Curious George
no damn way didn't have that book
growing up as a kid yes I did at this
book didn't this is Curious George you
know I know who it is famous and I'm too
old to be no one else
no one's else spidey-sense goes off when
you see a grown man in a Curious George
sweatshirt drinking Pedialyte with that
haircut I'm not drinking that's a white
sand that's a pee like popsicle did I'm
off the bottle I'm not doing it but you
look like every character from the first
48 show oh dude that sure that says good
man julia has one of the best jokes he
goes it's a show about they have 48
hours to solve a crime but really they
have as much time as they want
it's much time you know what there's so
six months later they wrap the case I'm
like what's that called [ __ ] first
six months dude and they're really just
busting black people for doing stuff why
don't they call the show what it is you
know
well that's cops yeah no I think they
change that's been on there for 13 years
because of that um yeah I think much man
yeah dude you just look a little strange
you look like you you look like you were
styled by [ __ ] Freddie Mercury side
piece it's a nice sweater man who it's
not it's creepy at your age be wearing
that then you got them busted shoes you
got that weird kitty sweater on you got
it oh yeah peanut butter in your pocket
and then all of a sudden your back
starts to give out why would you have
back problems live backwards from what I
used to collecting rocks as a kid l5 s1
I was Browz howler wearing Christmas
undies I had a spasm you goon
a spasm yeah sure it's George sweater
the beagle boy you look like one of the
beagle boys like semi handsome brother
tried to get into modeling from
ducktales straight up [ __ ] nice like
that look like an ice monster you
freaking mammal yes my back hurt and
that's why I'm down on the ground
because and nobody even tried to help me
some [ __ ] took a picture of me while
I was out there yeah you damn right they
did have an l5 s1 issue have you ever
had an L disc issues yeah I have like
this just wander around creep with a bad
disc no I go to the ground dude you look
like a lunch lady you got kicked in the
nuts what in the woman nuts bro in the
marver is he talking about
nah you know how to do was paint my
lunch lady made sloppy joes and had a
pair of nuts yeah bro you are a nice
lady dude you look definitely like one
of the most clean-cut lunch woman I've
ever wrote you look like a lunch lady
floppy Joe haircut I'll tell you this my
favorite lunch lady miss Annie and all
rest of rest in peace does she have nuts
no dude shoot about 770 hundred and
years old and she lived across the
street from us and her grandson actually
killed her damn favorite mustache
well she was old she just had at a
certain point all the hair that's in
your body is it goes out on your face
feel like lunch ladies age faster than
anybody here comes out did you have here
moles are not
I don't know about that dude I know that
she [ __ ] could double Scooby is so
fast though brother I mean before you
knew it yet extra you know and then and
then mine would always slip me a
strawberry milk an extra sterling Malka
bike thanks [ __ ]
first of all milk has an eye in it is
the second letter it's not a me LK so a
strawberry milk is Melek dude
yeah milk you've been drinking milk your
whole life
Denver dude where Denver Scotland given
drinking milk
who makes you mad Guinea
dude you know you're jealous cuz your
[ __ ] you listening folks and having a
man your shitty lunch lady never hooked
you up with strawberry she got murdered
by her grandson who had a Rottweiler
okay Wow and his name was Brad and he
never owned a shirt dude you always make
it dark bras just talking about [ __ ]
lunch ladies yeah and I was talking
about having them rest in peace and
their souls hoga that that lowered
double scoops you some [ __ ] greens
Annie rust and gravy baby hey PWA I used
to get a detention you'd have kitchen
Patrol with Annie and you'd have to
stand there next to Annie while she did
the scooping dude and it was arresting
government cheese babies nothing that
made your neck sweat more and but that's
how you became friends and those were
the good old days when you stand next to
your enemy with your hands on their
shoulders you do that you know so r.i.p
dude and uh should we our IP Brendan oh
yeah let's do it
here's Brendan you look like an extra
from Dallas buyers
oh yeah that's pretty good thanks I'll
give you a point for that one
okay here's Brendan right here that's a
point bro that's a point Delphi is what
sang still in here you know how we roll
we'll wait for that segment go ahead and
rip that swaggy swaggy drip drip oh my
what's up right
but you look like first of all a Persian
coal miner okay they have cool - huh
no but it's just a guy that stands
outside of the [ __ ] mine complaining
about [ __ ] stealing all the gold so
that's what you look like right there
and what is that dude you look like you
look like a strong you look like a gay
hitman that's what you look like
that's you'd like like well don't worry
boss I'm gonna do [ __ ] suck the guy's
dick Tilly dying oh dude hitmen suck
dick not gay a gay hitman do they shoot
him then psycho figure this out bro
it's a logic is all over the place my
bro you let your logic dripped out of
your ear in a frickin octagon bro you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about log is hangout the backyard there
going guy who got see all season home
school mom Devi sees yeah mom mama
[ __ ] see mom was a tough teacher dude
and she didn't let us aww and she didn't
let she didn't give a study guides makes
sense all right let's see some of these
other yeah okay a gay hitman dollars
here's the first one fan submission from
Ashley Peters Ashley Peters was a no
damn scrolling
what is she sip is she's sipping on
something she's a she and I have the
same nose I'd go with that start there
can we start there you have the same
hair as well rip my drip rip my
hairstyle you and her have the existing
out my snout bro look at that snout can
you zoom in on that snout she gets the
potato nose - it's not a potato you did
say some oxygen for everybody else in
the room dude up but all you guys just
sleep in a heartbeat well I'll hold it
all in and leave just a little bit of
monoxide for you for the lightweight bra
yeah well I'm gonna [ __ ] shoot a gay
guy like your boss told you to you creep
dude why don't you sell me some aids
viruses why Dallas buyers club bro
it's called DBC don't [ __ ] pronounce
it everytime whitout can we get a outlet
out looking we look at her from the
outside
dude what does she sipping on also it's
the middle of the day she seems like
she's hammered that's true hammered a
lot oh I've seen that she's off
intervention yeah I knew it I knew I
she's off the show intervention on a
knee yeah she does my famous bro and she
seemed like a very nice you know up like
a lady that kind of drinks during the
day but also probably holds up a job
like you don't have that you know she
has on oh you mean function alcohol oh
yeah oh yeah yeah she's like a
functional alcoholic she has a
uh ballet dress on she looks like the
funnest aunt in the world yeah she
definitely she looks like the ant but
actually in this picture can we zoom out
a little more their neck it looks like
she has just cornered a underaged person
in a bedroom and wants to tell her about
her new job yeah
she corners you in the corner and tell
you about the movie she just and she
keeps talking and talking and talking to
you bust all over and then she goes to
jail for taking advantage of youngsters
Oh interesting I've been involved with
this type of lady look at her legs are
going chief God put her legs on the
wrong sockets you they the left foots on
the right thigh lights on the left
she's doing that yeah sometime when
you're turned on the Lord just bakes the
Hokey Pokey right into you know she
looks hydrated though I'll give her that
Oh looks hydrated likes all the hydrate
yeah shout out to that aunt yeah set in
the world seemed like a beautiful la
woman what's her name Sandra Ashley
Peters Ashley Peters alright the next
one from John Brantley rip his drip
goddamn John look at that powerful beard
John looks like he's trying to [ __ ] a
fly he that's just a the vibe he's
giving off bro and what's his sweater
say you've messed with the wrong woman
exactly tattoos on the hand clearly a
felon orange cap he has a snitch cap
going on and then he has a powerful
powerful [ __ ] man bag dude this is a
woman's marcher first of all I think oh
no you know he's the mascot for the me
to movement yeah this guy uh Wow he does
at that man pouch he has the michael
who's that killer from Halloween Michael
just Michael Annett never last night
yeah he has the Michael Martin Michael
Martin pants no there's no Martin bro
just Michael from the Michael yeah it
has a lasting no he doesn't bro you
think his name's Michael something
there's Freddy Krueger but there's just
Michael no there isn't
it's Mike Myers oh my god right what did
you call Michael David's yeah you call
Mike Myers don't turn it on me here to
call Mike Myers Michael Martin yeah
Michael Martin dude who sounds like a
killer and it's
Michael Myers not just Michael Michael
Michael yeah my house whose home just
Mike scary Mike what that's insane no
yeah just everybody get crash is just
scary my idiot I'll tell you about this
scary Mike though that shady [ __ ]
rusted out house behind them there's
definitely some dead bodies back there
dude what broads tied down oh that's a
straight-up bone shag dude he's an ass
tied down bro and this guy remind me of
a fellow this dude I you knew in this
name Wayne and everybody called him wild
Wayne people always called Wayne's wild
Wayne and they're not well here's a
[ __ ] Wayne Wayne he was a while no
none of them are and uh but they call
him wild Wayne and he um you know
raccoons have a bone at the base of
their Johnson you know Lee yeah and they
would he would make necklaces out of him
his family had unlimited raccoons around
their area like a voodoo god yeah a kind
of voodoo jewel or really but anyway
this guy looks like somebody that would
be doing that out there like oh he has
that man pouch I could have a little
bitty saw in there where he's just he
looks like he works with his hands it
looks like he makes lamps out of human
skin or some [ __ ] oh it's hand ammonium
once this dude [ __ ] gets anyone he
has his Michael Myers legs and boots
night but he see I love his hat his an
orange hat for safety here's that seer
of killer swag about him like he's put
together well but I don't want to touch
her
well he doesn't come into town much you
know unless he needs maybe milk or or
something he's what we refer to as an
outsider yeah what else we got a deal
Sunday a big day my man yeah big day
without my Saints in it yeah but I know
you're sad about it you don't be sad bro
cuz you make Bank it's Super Bowl Sunday
y'all it's the biggest sporting event of
the year yes Sunday Super Bowl Sunday
and it's your last opportunity to play
fantasy football this season your final
opportunity with single game showdown
and that is the newest way to play at
draftkings y'all that's right the big
game by offering you guys a free shot at
1 million dollars that's right with your
first deposit you at 1 million dollars
you get a chance at 1 million dollars
you could
yeah good read the direct to share the 1
million if you win it yeah win it will
you give me something yeah ten percent
bro oh I'll give you ten dollars oh wow
it's selfish yeah but it's more than you
had if you're thinking about trying
draftkings now's the time when you're
gonna try in the summer you're gonna bet
on soccer and Australia or Austria you
bet on pre-season yeah bad on now's the
time bra Sunday we're you get a bet on
the crime rate in Johannesburg yeah what
are you in bet on the temp in Chicago
summer all you have to do is draft six
players from the big game one captain in
five other players yep your captain will
earn one point five times the points you
can go for value or for star power to
anchor your line up this is crazy this
is crazy bro it's that simple six
players from one game just stay under
the salary cap and see how your team
stacks up against the competition stacks
up stack it up stack it
go to draftkings.com or download the app
now now now for a limited time use code
cats
that's cats with a K yeah K ATS to enter
the all new single game showdown contest
for free this Sunday with your first
deposit and compete for the $1,000,000
top prize
that's code K ATS only at draft
kings.com became inside the game who
minimum $5 deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply so you drive can talk
down for details whoa it's time for
debate club first one we got from Justin
Gilkey hey guys this is Jason from
Austin Texas and I have a debate club
topic for you Kelly Kapowski or Topanga
come on bro Brendan Kelly Kapowski or
[ __ ] tip it Kelly kept at Kapowski
verse air buddy
and she was the best oh hi jack
relentless listen Charlie that's oh man
and sometimes every now and then I'd
throw an AC Slater just to mix it up
yeah Oh bro I mean if I did have one
vision
one time when I came into the air and
then he caught it in his dimple Oh Oh
screech though for you I know no yeah no
you look like a screech fan no I don't
at all
screech stabbing likes creatures older
brother haunted what was screeches hold
her brother's name Co food uh topanga's
hot as [ __ ] though - she was on the
cover of Maxim like ten years ago she's
doing the damn thing
she's if you like him a little thicker
that was her Topanga was for the thick
kids Topanga was cute that was the thing
Oh Kelly was not Topanga was cute cute
doesn't age well that's really I'm
telling you well check out this cuteness
boom what's up bro full set of tits to
bang it down
Topanga Dania wait was that her that's
her bro
well BOSU man more she's a horrible
shakes great to get that [ __ ] little
boner out mmm that look how what do they
saw part of her head in she looks at who
she is delicious how tall is she
6 - I think you look about all she has
please 6-2 6-4 I don't know she's 6
- dude something up 5-3 how tall is
Kelly Kapowski 5 wine or a 5-1 yeah
and a white girl fine yeah cute doesn't
age well man I'm saying talking about
she's a straight-up dying piece no it
looks like oh look at Kelly Kapowski ID
she ate all the food at the max really
get her bro what are you talking about
Dylan Kapowski ate all the fries at the
Mad Max right yet poor kids bro dude
Topanga had seven no yeah Wow Kelly
looks like she said I definitely had a
long like 2005 was a long yeah like
where I looked at still Kelly all day
took Kelly no Kelly as a kid the Kelly
when we were kids
no one hotter she's no wine and I was
even mad at least a turtle but as a kid
but now it's Topanga mmm dude Topanga is
he's a life II son as well as a dolt its
Topanga she's a kids old he's 5 1 she
seems chatty
she seems like a real [ __ ] on the show
to be honest she didn't even give that
kid that time of day and she was you
boss sweep out Kelly Kapowski
in blue balling our boy Zack Morris for
years never sucked him off name in a
[ __ ] a simple [ __ ] in the am job
on that show dude J you can dude screech
got him all the time oh Lisa turtle did
it for him yeah have you missed that
episode know it yeah I'm Belding walked
in and then jacked off on him God should
we see the results yeah yeah it's gonna
be Kelly Kapowski she's so much by uh by
long ham slide bro oh [ __ ] it's very
close though see my fellow to paying
your fans out there they know what's up
Topanga Lawrence she's related to Joey
Lawrence or not I don't think so I think
they're both fictional name or hers is
fictional both Joey's real characters
next one please
all right the next one for debate club
Topanga do put anybody else up there
Topanga Palace Keefe next one from Alex
Mundy all right
sup Brandon fields Alex from Houston
Texas I got a good question for y'all to
debate today what's more of a big dick
move walk-off home run in the World
Series to win or a three-point buzzer
beer to win finals let's hear em em as
far as big dick move it's when you take
that [ __ ] wooden bat and hit a
homerun off somebody I think it's dumb
play baseball slow the ball so much to
hit it with a bat as a dumbest [ __ ]
difficult sport it sounds like it's from
like the 1400 which it is yeah yeah oh
here I'm gonna throw this ball Steve can
hit it with that piece of wood bro
here's the thing we're talking about get
a [ __ ] ps4 you freaking freaks yeah
you could just play video games you
could so much better man I'd rather hit
a buzzer beater because you have it your
whole team is out there on the court if
you're playing baseball it's just you
then you're running around the bags by
yourself you have to run past the other
team if you hit that buzzer beater dude
you that bad boy and everybody's right
there you can see yourselves right right
boy yeah they dog pile on top of you
cheerleaders are right there baseball is
zero cheerleaders these are great points
you're just going in front of a bunch of
alcoholics dude and it's a lot of
daytime drinkers out there even why
that's the majority of yeah and it's so
slow I'm going basketball now I was
saying baseball baseball is more
difficult deal made the best points I'm
going MBA so you're over here debate
club I'm with you
next what's the fan say let's go to the
results we got 57 percent say World
Series home run cuz it's all it's all
you can kind of shoving that down the
pitchers throat you know I'm saying big
it's harder to do yeah good homerun
hitters gonna hit a home run about six
percent of time okay three point
shooters about forty percent shooting
for curry
big dick energies gonna get you arrested
it sounds like it seems like a term that
I'm not gonna be using because you could
go fat [ __ ] spirit that's how I was like
a kid who play kickball growing up
though yeah played kickball a lot of
freeze tag by himself dude now so you
just stayed in place he's no friend of
light freeze to hang around till someone
came along with what the hell you doing
with your it and then ran across oh
thank you is always a freak yeah was
that you what else I got the next one
from our man Wow dude I want that gotta
take my sister dude dude I want to be my
friend just live in my backseat
give me motivational yeah advice as I'm
driving down the highway I like that you
will end up in a high-speed chase from
the police if that guy was your uber
driver if he's your friend yeah problems
blame dirty Benjamin j-rod j-rock sorry
I didn't hear it correctly yeah like
shuttled here that hey rod yeah gelatin
bra
j-rock all his submissions are about
going to the bathroom though oh yeah
your nose person also has some sort of
bowel problems Oh dirty artist be honest
I like that here's a dirty artist so
it's either baby wipes or bidet bidet is
old school have you ever done a bidet my
uncle had a bidet ass house I thought
there's a water fountain next to the
toilet and they it gets mad
see real-ass see baby wipes all day bro
oh I wouldn't mind a bad day if the
water is warm it depends on if you're
getting water fresh out of a stream into
a bidet I wouldn't take something
naturally out of the earth right on him
a butthole
I don't worry man well the iron that
could be in that you get mercury in your
bloodstream is trying to clean your ass
huh so I think if they had like a chart
that showed the water table or something
or where the water was coming from I'll
take you know purified water on my ass
he'll turd I don't need filtered you
[ __ ] creep I just need something at
least that has been you know inoculated
a little bit I don't want that [ __ ]
that's straight out of [ __ ] you know
out of the devil's bowel coming right at
my ass dude
dude a lot of the water has Turk turbo
sites in it all kind of [ __ ] I don't
know what that is where you don't drink
the LA tap water you turn into a [ __ ]
teenager you don't want that going up
your [ __ ]
oh that's why I say baby wives yeah or I
would just wipe my ass and then go home
that's what I usually do yeah I usually
just use the normal toilet paper then
[ __ ] hit the road yeah but baby wipes
are nice baby wipes are a plus in this
summer I'll keep some in my car yeah
sometimes I'll wipe my ass even if I
have even gone to the bathroom me too
just cheesy done then my new thing is go
pee in the toilet then sit on and wipe
my butt oh that's weird
you think mm yeah pretty weird dude but
would you rather be that guy or the guy
that doesn't do that that guy has
problems though there's anybody notice
he looks like he just committed a crime
yeah yeah dude he looks like you just
robbed all the bay and then does videos
for us every week he's on the run anyone
notice that dude he robbed a bank bro
that would help this podcast blow up so
much because if he some subliminally
gave us clues through the hose videos or
is a good idea or every bank he robbed
he put pass a note and put gang gang
yeah that's what we need to play club
I'm about to rob this [ __ ] or not good
I rob erred
net hog
what else we got the results of bday
verse baby white 76% go baby way yabba
days for an older generation for God's
sakes
well bidet is a it's just you know it's
uh it's messy bro
splash display if it doesn't splash on
to the floor
dude if that's you you had a hose I
think is what you had you might be right
I mean Arden hose come from the outside
the window
and I thought that was a bidet as a kid
it's different what else you got the
next one from Mason more what's up y'all
driving right now play some more come at
you hot I let him said it twice broke
vase to make a more dick aka first-team
all dimepiece well ah I'd say stay on
Deena's or Nike and I'm pretty sure
Theo's pay doesn't count on this one I'm
not sure he can spell adidas
d-dang buzz buzz gang brah I love this
dude
Oh deed us there you go you know what
adidas stands for huh
you know adidas stands for uh-uh all day
I dream about soccer really that's the
rumor
who cares that'll help you spell it bro
tell your mom that next time she's
teaching [ __ ] I'll tell your mom
something you idiot saying is this what
I do there adidas would he yeah uh Pumas
on alright I got on these Pumas from
Josh wolf that he gave me over to show
nice he's always shoveling Puma that guy
got me 17 pairs of Pumas yeah alright
dude outside of his house on all the
power lines like 70 pairs of poom was
just wrapped around then he has a
real-life Puma in his house all right
bro get out of here get [ __ ] you mean
your Puma so adidas right now is the
hotness cuz all the Yeezys I'm over
Yeezys Nikes been doing it way long
everyone its Nike Nike all day Nikes
fall apart though I think Nikes don't
last that long maybe the ones in
Louisiana fall apart yet in the rest of
the world they stay pretty well together
you think yeah man
Jordans are Nikes son yeah first of all
who's buying Michael Jordan shoes that
guy's 64 years old now everybody's
buying them yeah I got Pumas that Josh
wolf gave you that's right dude you know
free Pumas from a friend that are
keeping my feet warm
you selfish piece of [ __ ] its Nike all
day and I'm closed adidas is high boy
adidas is good and I'll tell you why
adidas has matching tracksuits that you
and your children can wear if you guys
are extremely poor or Italian okay I
grew up outside of Louisiana and if a
family really loved each other they show
up in a beautiful all matching group of
[ __ ] track suits really need a stir
together really cuz where I'm from if
you all were the same thing you were
[ __ ] yeah that's strange whatever a
difference in O'Doyle rules bro you but
if you do lace together bro
so leave the [ __ ] vote Nikes easy
it's the cheap Betsy it's you know it's
the it's the constant bro yeah Gordon
its basis Kyrie Irving it's the basic
[ __ ] element your Force Ones are hot
right now they have the off-white
collection I know it sounds like I'm
speaking [ __ ] Persian to you smoking
Nick just got the premature Nick just
got the mochas Jordan threes not mad at
those you know what's up Nick hey take a
hike bro I'm going to take a hike and
when I do I'll do it in Adidas tracksuit
yes good listening make you a better
parent bro do you think dude I think so
I listen to books on tape all the time
at audible for my son really I don't
want it I don't say but it's what people
are talking about in LA
that's that of the really and it's
because I honorable oh wow it's cuz
audible bro oh yeah books on tape about
parenting Oh your son seemed like a real
prize winner when I met him
thanks bro yeah man I mean I guess I
could listen to books on tape about
Fitness about you know gun care it's
been a better person yeah history yeah
sports yeah Loch Ness monster sure why
not
whatever you want and there's never been
a better time to start listening than on
audible with audible you get access to
an unbeatable selection of audio books
including bestsellers motivation
mysteries thrillers memoirs and more
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet and now with
audible originals the selection has
gotten even more custom with content
made for the members yeah it used to be
I'd to walk around in the bookstore and
like see look find somebody who looked
like you and then see what they picked
out to know what you would like yeah or
you got in you got a whisper you can't
really be yourself in the bookstore you
can't anymore man yes yell in your car
look you could set your car on fire as
long as the radio still working yeah you
can listen on any device anytime
anywhere at home the gym your commute or
just on the go
heck even if you rob a bank and you're
on the run from the cops you could enjoy
the great gatsby yeah at least you're
learning yeah you know kill kill two
birds one stone
yeah just don't kill anybody at the bank
yeah and learn your history as you go
audible the most inspiring minds the
most compelling stories the best place
to listen get started with a 30-day
trial when you go to audible.com slash
cats that's cats with a ke ke ATS can't
spell that price should be listen to
books or tax cats - 500 500 and listen
for a change
that's right that's K 80s to five zero
zero five zero zero and listen for a
change
Wow go to audible.com slash K 80s or
text K 80s to 500 500 and get your
30-day free trial at audible
all right it is time for flaunt my aunt
alright beautiful lady submitted I want
to say this too about flaunt mine we've
had a lot of beautiful women submitted
and and you know our goal is to uplift
these ladies and make people feel you
know hopeful and excited hit it here's
the first one from submitted by Jack
case
god dammit the lead singer of the White
Stripes broke his air quotes aunt
oh you mean uncle no it's shirt says
Venus this is a female have some
repertoire of decency
dude that's someone's uncle from the 80s
look at the fan in the back look at the
is that pedialite know that listen Mike
Miller's let my life not some Mike's
heart it's a 40 oh [ __ ] that's a 40 gang
if that's always I'll bro if three belts
on a little preamble bro Efendi and a
supreme it's triple that was it clearly
he's rich or the lock in that pod
somebody's uncle that plays a mean
[ __ ] bass what are you talking about
no it says women are from Venus on the
shirt it's not don't matter bro he might
be rather than me - movement it's an
angry lady that didn't feel like cared
about by man when they were young so now
this is the way that they're behaving oh
that's a dude who does he's a cover band
for Whitesnake Whitesnake dude ever
heard of how bi knows yeah they are an
endangered species and they also play
music what you're a Whitesnake well I've
heard a Whitesnake I've seen Whitesnake
at the zoo I've seen white alligator
note the pain [ __ ] the band
you've seen a band of white snakes dude
there's all your white snake watch him
ethnic educate this bull won't you call
your doctor dad your mom ripped out the
[ __ ] music some mom is the Traveling
Wilburys dude and she was a good woman
and she still is dude you tell me that
uncle doesn't look like one of these do
whatever who was that this is a lady she
looks nice his eyeglasses on look at
this thin lip Suman on those lips Nikki
he's got a guitar around her uh back
there is that another is that a some
sort of satchel look at that she's kind
of sexy look at this I uh the eyebrows a
soft hand on the belt look at the soft
skin is that an MTV button on her badge
- it says Best Buy on it Jesus Christ
you don't know MTV is spelled not with a
B no she worked up drinking a 40 she's
standing you're a [ __ ] fan so she's
got a 40 he's down at being a struggling
environment we don't have proper air
flow I like this bad [ __ ] what's her
name no name no name no name the river
you can nave the Ripper beautiful young
lady
thank you very much seems like a nice
woman thank or a handsome young man
either way she's and he is killing it
yeah won't you all fall asleep and watch
a band of [ __ ] white snakes play heard
the band Whitesnake number two sent in
the submitter didn't put their name but
this is aunt Alexandra let's see her
unless she seems like a nice person oh
damn in the snow have yet a little
frozen vibe going in summer yes you've
seen the movie bro uh what movie The
Bodyguard says Whitney Houston about to
get shot outdoors Wow see I don't get a
Whitney Houston vibe at all here though
really at all no I get a mrs. Doubtfire
vibrant you don't say yeah roses fire at
me she's about to get shot at have you
seen the bodyguard dude this has a very
shoot me outdoors in the snow type of
vibe I get more of the edge vibe here
the edge what the right move II the edge
oh I'm seeing out with Anthony Hopkins I
were getting chased by the grizzly bear
they're stuck outside yeah I would never
watch something like that it seems like
a how long is oh dude white girl with
dreads she has dreads bro you missed the
dreads deal yeah and I would drag Oh
kiss bro his dreads I would dread
sleeping in that lady's bags prowl
doesn't wash her bedsheets dude smells
like always hey we got to do laundry
like dreadlocks I agree they stink yeah
dude when when you walk through a pet
store and all the animals come see
edge of the cage because of jealousy out
of your [ __ ] can during work when the
hamsters would eat your dreads yeah when
you're running around with a bug in 14
inches of feed hanging off of your scalp
come on but still outside of that man
she seems very happy she's outdoor she's
a nice smile all of her teeth his eyes
yes yep she's just the blue vibe going
on blue jacket a nice skirt she looks
like she knit scarves for gifts she
guess she keeps her body warms probably
warm has a warm body that's good she's a
lot going for her yeah
besides the dreads good luck yeah and
give her a hug for us you seem like
she's really up to some good stuff all
right the next one also anonymously
submitted Nikki win a gun indoors she is
somebody's aunt with that pipe bomb bro
she in a fire something like she might
have been in a fire dude
she can jump into my arms in the fire
she's somebody's hand is filthy here's a
gun he has vaseline all over her face
yeah bro yeah okay she was in a fire I'm
guessing I'm not a fire she cooks out
had her mouth look at her she get too
close to a kettle I am looking at her
dude what some another face what's wrong
with her face very pretty
hope she's doing well she seemed like
yeah maybe she okay she just lost a
layer of skin maybe she's got a facial
one of those like uh oh yeah when you
first get a facial on your skin's
irritated like drippy wet yeah gets very
sticky like a frog's hand yeah that's
what's going on there that's what's
going I guess she looks like she gives
the meanest happy guy that ever failed
biology I guess um she looks like yeah I
mean she look like she gives a way happy
ending bro and also a sad ending or she
will shoot your nuts right off your body
oh no II shouldn't god she looks like
sure Jackie off with her feet hey I'm
Brown have a problem with I don't think
that's true Nick knows what I'm talking
about I'm gonna pay double for that bro
no I mean yeah you do know her and also
looks like her house is a mess as well
but that's whatever she's busy bro this
clearly is this hallow
I don't think so this is a typical
Tuesday yeah this is Nick Quinn oh yeah
they seem like West Virginia just like
an average afternoon in West Virginia
just wandering around the house and some
[ __ ] leg tights and she's in Shh
tall tall heels got chokers whole times
which is very unique are those real leg
do you think she yeah those are real she
looks like she looks like she's gonna
you could put on the [ __ ] Big Trouble
in Little China and eat a [ __ ] 12
piece of chicken wings yeah she jacked
you off oh dude she looks like she could
[ __ ] cook a frog in her mouth if she
wanted to yeah we all she looks like a
very chef she's like a female chef maybe
she looks like she eats Funyun yeah she
could just put a couple eggs on a plate
and just shoot that gun at him and just
[ __ ] boom and omelette right your
mouth seems like yeah like just really I
choose some unique ways to cook she
looks like she made top ROM and put
double the seasoning it oh yeah dude she
looked like she make Top Ramen bottom
ramen dude she looks like she's
definitely given a ramen enema to
somebody she's like she could be a nurse
and I'd pay him Taiwan Earth and Saigon
so she seemed like a cool lady that
could also work at a pet store she's a
lot of I think of pets throw out and get
that back yeah she could be a doctor as
well look at that mm Wow
doctor yeah also I don't get that vibe
really get a masseuse vibe I get a an
extra on crazy rich Asian I get a she
doesn't me describe yeah I didn't think
about that she does look pretty Asia a
little bit Asian and all the shoes are
by the door that's a very Asian ah dude
very Asian you [ __ ] touch me bro
whether you're talkin torn up and I
asked to build a wall right here between
me and Ian alright Trumpy uh is that it
that does it for flaunt my honors we
ended on a positive note we did yeah
hell yeah
she'll grill up some mean-ass [ __ ]
ribs for you if you want
oh I'd let that lady shoot me right in
the [ __ ] dick with a titty gun bro
she's hot yeah oh yeah she's a great
dick away bro dude I know what you're
thinking I know what I'm thinking you've
been sleeping around yeah I have been
sleeping around on Casper mattresses oh
it's the only mattress I sleep on you
come to my house I can't get people to
leave they go dude I don't know what it
is but this is the best bet I've ever
been
it's Casper hmm now get your grimy body
off my bed yeah get out of my house get
out of here you've been here since
Thanksgiving yeah
Ben this is John 16 get out of here you
gotta go yeah that free bro you're not
napping you're a freeloader yeah man
well you're a roommate at this point
Casper products are cleverly designed to
mimic human curves providing in
supportive comfort of all kind of bodies
your body you're vegan body my big
thickness body whatever but yeah dude
you seem like you definitely need to get
your body checked out bro the original
Casper mattress combines multiple
supportive memory foams for a quality
sleep surface with the right amounts of
both sink and bounce sink and bounce
bounce bounce sink you spend one third
of your life sleeping so you should be
sleeping in Casper yep with over 20,000
reviews and an average of 4.8 stars
across Casper Amazon and Google Casper
is becoming the Internet's favorite
mattress the only mattress Casper
Oster's to other matches the wave and
essential the way features a
patent-pending premium support system to
mirror the natural Wow can't believe you
got through that tears bro I've reached
it man what Brenda natural shape of yoga
knew that booty affordable prices
because Casper cuts out the middleman
you don't have to go to a shop or
there's like you know there's
fluorescent lights a creepy dude in the
khakis going what can I help you with a
bag you boy dad what do you think I'm
here for the foliage yeah I'm gonna sit
here and lay on these while you critique
me yeah you smell like Winston's bro
sell me a mattress or I'm getting out of
here delivered right to your door in a
small how do they do that sized box you
will never believe that there's a
mattress in the box you're right bro
what's in the box what's in the box but
it's a real hitter free shipping and
returns in the US and Canada yeah that's
right so get $50 toward a select
mattress by visiting Casper calm slash
tat that's cats with a carry man yup k
ATS Casper calm slash cats and you can
be sure of your purchase with Casper's
100 night risk-free sleep on it trial
you check it out for a hundred nights on
that ninety-ninth night bro if you ain't
sure you can ship it back which is weird
Casper come slash cats gay ATS terms and
commissions uh plot terms and conditions
apply Thanks time for king it or sting
it
you guys want pull out those buttons
you're [ __ ] right I do thought you'd
never ask
say no more aunt Gwyn Nikki win aunt
Gwen bro reluctantly pulling out the
button let's go bro let's go and this
first one could be trouble for Theo
it's from Elsa Asgard which I believe oh
yeah a fake name Elsa hey boys this is
Elsa calling from New York City we're
not cause so I shot my first porn film
the other day and it was anal and Sakura
Lee anal it's my first scene but I mean
I got paid double and I did hurt but I
kind of got into it towards the end and
the director gave me cookie after school
um oh and speaking of ass I saw there at
my drip segment last week and for you my
love all I got to say is baby got back
gang gang anyways anal sex King
interesting dude she wants to [ __ ] your
ass no she doesn't does yeah that's the
vibe I got from it
who is her what's her name again Elsa
else that ass guard
I thought you it from that movie um do
you want to build a snowman no do you
want to build no do you want to build a
snowman yeah let's not drag that into
this cuz that is not the Elsa I watch
well it looks like she by works like
that girl at parties I'll say this oh
she seemed like a you know like a lady
that's really thinking about her future
you don't think that she's trying to get
a job I think she got taken advantage of
it sounds like it's a doctor gave her
your sex no they gave her a cookie cuz
there's the first time she let someone
go in the [ __ ] crap or shoot yeah and
then it also appears that she wants to
[ __ ] your ass
well I said I watched that ripping the
rip and the drip and feel you baby got
back I got some junk in the trunk no he
doesn't
yeah these glasses I got that Jam he
needs glasses bro I got a trip the
flattest ass I've ever seen you can't
see then dude I can see perfectly fine
yeah yeah bro keep the ass of screech
it's not good and she wants to touch it
I got that Jimmy one else get that vibe
that she wants to lick feels [ __ ]
whoa whoa
first of all also get your [ __ ] boner
off of my table dude okay I'm gonna tell
you Pio it seems a master like George
Bush just died Nam okay yeah and I'll
say this you got that sheshe knows I got
that junk in the trunk I got that Jay in
the Trey little you little [ __ ]
skittle monkey okay and I don't know if
she wants that rainbow she wants that
ROYGBIV you know she wants daddy to uh
pop colors all up in that boot ah so
I'll say this you know we'll see about
it okay I don't know so not down to the
day that [ __ ] for I don't know this
woman first of all I'm down to maybe get
a coffee or something and talk or
something he seems coffee and talk
there's no coffee and talk I'm not
letting this woman near my butt unless
she works for a professional
organization that helps people you know
maybe wax their butt or that is somebody
know if she have a doctor's diploma she
might so Luke in your sting at anal if
she goes to medical school then I then
anal but if somebody's just freelance
some [ __ ] [ __ ] bootleg nerdy hole
know some bootleg nurse driving a ah it
can't be no Allie booty hole yeah what's
going on I mean I think has to be
someone you kind of get to know at least
over you know uh snapchat which I think
you guys could do I don't know but she's
you look did she say she's a nurse but
she didn't say anything no no profession
need to accept aspiring actress actress
I guess oh uh oh oh I'll solve it yeah
porno star mother corners porno star
okay okay case solved well I don't I
don't watch pornography I'm 54 days off
pornography right now so you're PL bro
you watch that but you know I'd love to
hear about some more of her
experiences but um we appreciate you
reaching out hey bro hey King under
sting it ain't a lot say this Christ I
think he does the life advice okay so
good guys drop loads in her [ __ ]
whoa you got your life advice right she
said she's working with a doctor okay
yeah that's a fake doctor with a huge
[ __ ] is it really does it say it's
literally metaphors here and he gave her
a cookie yeah she'd uh the cookie was
busted all over her face bro oh man God
you've been alley game too long it feels
like she's getting caught up in some
stuff maybe she should seek some
assistance I think all right man king of
sting get anal but I'm gonna say for me
I'm planning on keeping my butt just
right for the Lord you know the only way
I'm getting animals whenever I go back
to the Lord
yeah I'm not saying that you're gonna be
done in the booty do you like to do it
to girl oh I mean if they are adults and
the people have been discussing it
people have been discussing it for a
while yeah you down yeah man yeah I meet
you I'm in King anal but I don't think
just people dry was a long road though
bro you try to give her advice she just
wants to get [ __ ] man yeah well she ah
damn oh you didn't see the cry for a
help video that she [ __ ] said how I
didn't see that at all bro this is
trying to get beauty
you giving advice on a medical bill well
this is the modern-day throw a message
in a bottle and throw it into the
frickin really river to you and me yeah
and this [ __ ] just tossed that into the
Hudson bro she wants to she's obviously
been taking advantage of how brother
Travis ghost or no we didn't get views
well I'm not doing anything like that
no yeah we ought to run it by your Bo
see what he says all right number two
for King under sting it from TRAI hoobin
oh wow brother
straight from Boston I wanted to hear
what you guys think of women that
proposed to their boyfriends it's kind
of weird to me I don't know if I do it
but some men like it I'm not sure what
do you guys think of it can't get worse
dang it is that an angel from Austin
good on ya look at those eyes and the
hair and the lips let's try a Reuben I
thought he was gonna be a shooting guard
that's a beautiful young daddy she is
gorgeous yeah doesn't me a shooting
guard from Kentucky and also they could
be yeah it's a beautiful young lady that
Jack still thick Ross and whatever girl
she got that quarter if you dressed like
Chris D'Elia
she is that crystally a jacket on a
little bit orange flamingo colored
[ __ ] corduroy
that's way crystal yeah but you seem
like a nice lady trophy star and I'll be
in Boston at the Wilbur theater Austin
[ __ ] is it Austin I have to yeah yeah
it sound like Austin that's a thick coat
Frost and they'll feel my baby's train
from Boston Boston and so I'm gonna say
this don't [ __ ] touch them I didn't
touch you you put your hand out there
I'll say this
TRAI I'll be in Boston at the Wilbur
theater so you to get a tray it's almost
sold out but I will say this also that
you women propose into dudes uh-uh
I say no hell no look we can't let's be
honest there's some things you don't
want you know take that from us yeah and
who's what guys give me like yeah this
is cool
a little rate of [ __ ] Muppet bro
Muppet Babies think that yeah I'm not
some [ __ ] meek little guy that's
never even used a hammer some guy that
probably works you know he doesn't even
work he got laid off from Geek Squad
don't know how to change a tire
only it's orange starburst yeah propose
that that dude yeah some guy that lives
with his mom yeah but now if it's some
woman that wants to be you know taking
advantage of a guy and like manipulation
and that sort of thing then go do your
thing ladies that's fine but just know
the guy that you ask that that says yes
I think it's gonna be a rare instance
where it's cool he'll know it's gonna be
corner if you proposed your man you
might as well [ __ ] him in there
down the road Jesus Christ that's how
the homegirl kicked it off bro I'm gonna
say she's not she's Drive not her the
though you're the sister your sister
Elsa will get your mind out of the dang
gutter my aunt
Elsa did was freaking me out man well
that's gone now and what's here now is
trail what's her name
Trey Trey hoobin no we call a Trey Trey
I know her
TRAI hoobin and then HOH I think and she
um what was her question
women proposing yeah are stinging and I
say sting it man sting it yeah women
just find something else to do give us
yeah yeah there's some sticker we don't
do that you guys do you know so just
don't do everything that we do like what
though huh like what do they do that we
don't do here's an example or the next
one from Bradley Martin what's happening
this is Brad coming at you from Slidell
Louisiana gang me and the guys at work
had a little bit of a debate today one
of my co-workers had just come back from
getting a massage and he was talking
about the guy who gave him a massage and
I said if they would have gave me a dude
I would have asked for a chick yeah and
they said they had no problems with a
dude masseuse your friend okay
qinger staying at man old man massage
action dude I didn't sting and it's not
it's just I just can't relax when a dude
is touch me like that it's just me and
I'm not homophobic or anything like that
I just can't get into my happy place
yeah I like a big thick borderline fat
girl to just get on my muscles and get
really in there with her elbows oh yeah
a problem is they breathe heavy yeah
I'll take up all the oxygen then they
start sweating and then I get on focus
and you so it's a fine line yeah I've
had a small asian girl really get in
gritty in there definitely no dudes oh I
get that thigh massage where they walk
up and down your back and stuff I had
this one little bitty uh Vietnamese lady
I think she might have fallen directly
into my ass bro while she was walking
down my back I mean so with a heel heel
dude she could do a spinning Turner kick
and land right on my [ __ ] spine bro
and just so long felt good though Oh bro
I'll [ __ ] remember to algebra when she
[ __ ] hit me hard
so I there were some very special
moments that a lot of these ladies can
do if some [ __ ] big dude that's been
up all night eatin [ __ ] snacks and
like you know crying on the phone to his
mom is gonna then get on my back and
walk up and down it solve my problems
with his hands dude forearms like Popeye
[ __ ] now sting that [ __ ] hell yeah dude
that's easy bro dang that and if your
boy likes to leave at lunch and let
another man [ __ ] soften his body up
dude then maybe you should uh talk to
him more okay and introduce them to some
strong women because you don't have to
go all the way to a man sometime you can
stop at a strong woman around and solve
your problems right there which is what
I do yeah I have a couple of friends
that are dating man now and they're like
[ __ ] man I should have just dated a
strong woman like yeah you should I've
seen a thousand times yeah
and it's there's that middle ground
there's that tough girl you know there's
that arm wrestler you know some chick
named Janet or TIFF you know they're out
there get out there get in there all
right the next run from Khloe Ellie hey
you guys these are white strips just to
clear that up question King it or sting
it women who cuss a lot
I myself have quite a dirty mouth and my
brother will always call me out on it
and say Khloe no guy is gonna want to
end up being with you because you curse
like a sailor I follow that up with [ __ ]
you I just wanted to know y'all's
opinion on that anyways love you guys do
especially you marry me skidding you
think she was kidding or not I don't
know I feel like she was serious you
shouldn't like a jokester but I was
gonna say yes but she just said I'm not
kidding
no she's seriously and not kidding so
you got a proposal dude I feel like
having a good day the one girl wanted to
do you in the booty and have you do her
in the booty who knows what that girl
wanted and also I don't need a napkin
a cry for help maybe but let's just take
it for what it is and then you just got
proposed to bro yeah well it's my lucky
Curious George sweater yeah creepy in
the least that's it kind of happens when
you take care of yourself and show up to
work as a professional not like you who
doesn't even remember I was the whole
alphabet before he leaves the house
dude you Peter like in [ __ ] this
doing it was a popsicle wait so what
hurt oh girls who cus there's a fine
line keep you dropping f-bombs all
goddamn day I can't bring around the
family no I'm saying it gets a little
less sexy although she was kind of sexy
with it yeah but it also did your
hottest [ __ ] I'll put up with some yeah
Grilli oh you called my mom whatever you
want if you're hot enough go ahead and
salt it girl suck this dick on the road
home you know I'm saying to him you know
okay you guys any it sounds like people
are sucking dick all the time over by
you what I'm saying it's their smile hi
what's her name again dandruff Chloe le
close though Chloe seemed like a nice
lady she's Scottish or from somewhere
and I'll say this that Chloe what was
she asking about when girls who cuss oh
yeah you don't have any brains
I don't mind it once in a while you know
I don't mind it around the holidays you
know like aw [ __ ] love this mistletoe
or something like that but I don't want
some girl who's just like ah [ __ ] it's
Wednesday
you know yeah I need you to I need to
use it yeah you're degrading it when you
use it too much yeah I don't need you
know just like a waitress from amherst
mass you know I got fine it's get a
[ __ ] sandwich yeah Frank died you
know I don't need that I need so once in
a while I don't mind it I don't mind it
during sex if somebody's being sexual if
somebody's don't [ __ ] [ __ ] touch me
don't touch me and I asked you guys to
put something here not a wall but a plan
or something at least yeah if you come
over here not allowed in go back home
and take your kids over there too we're
trying to get our free medical oh wow so
what I'm saying is this then we need to
allow what was this girl talking a
military real fast girls Lucas yes
occasionally I think it's good you know
Easter you guys are looking outside of
the church with the kids and she's like
where are these [ __ ] eggs you know
that kind of stuff it's fun but I think
yeah some ladies just dropping f-bombs
into the salad that she's making in the
kitchen bro I'm out sexy on Christmas
like I love [ __ ] Christmas like damn
girl like you got no one to use it yeah
yeah and it's uh but then everybody's
different you know and I think over text
message and stuff like that it's fine
it's not enough to get away with it for
a little bit yeah and I think it just
depends if it's a sense of humor but I
like a lady that's a little bit more
classy a little more classy here and
there and then behind closed doors if
you want to throw it around if we're
playing Mario Kart and you're like eat
this [ __ ] banana peel princess oh I
like that yeah that's good one loser
yeah take that yeah but I don't think
more than two f-bombs in a day mmm for
me
yeah I'm go ahead so should we sting in
it's case by case it's case by case but
I'm gonna sting it if you're hot enough
I'll take it King it and what are these
buzzers even mean do they mean anything
it just ends the combo the next one from
Sara Vargas I huge fan of both of you
guys I love Tina Singh it picked this
clearly Pro Theo who picked them
it was Jin she's I'd like to put my chin
on those chin rests Bette ladies from
where breasting ham can she feed all the
children the end of both of you guys I
love you both but I love to heal a
little bit more um can't wait to see you
in a few weeks and I'll see that almost
beat tina sing it filters on your
pictures [ __ ] no that's some catfish
tendencies in Jesus because you she's
filtered right and cuts down about 30
pounds leaves the fat tits but in the
face and it cut it down give them bigger
eyes it's a form of catfish really yeah
cuz you see him personally goddamn pan
face yes they've been using these
filters
that's pandemonium dude I'll tell you
this man if they want a filter make a
real filter that shows us who you really
are
how about a filter that shows if you've
lied before to someone you care about
huh
preach dude what about a filter that
shows oh you
person might die of alcoholism or this
person is gonna sell all your [ __ ] on
the internet while you're out of town
how about a racist filter how about
filter I can't read yeah it's just your
face yeah yeah that's sound like a cry
for help kind of from Brennan but what
I'm saying is I don't mind a filter for
the first picture or two I don't mind it
occasionally but I don't think you can
do the full time filtering cuz at a
certain point it's just you hiding you
know like you can always tell like if a
girl doesn't have one I because in all
of her pictures she's like this you know
I've seen that she's like oh I just
ordered a coffee and it's you know I'm
just holding it by my face or it's like
you know she'll be hiding behind like a
little like a little black tree like
this like I was playing hide-and-go-seek
with my friends you know you're
basically wearing a mask yeah yeah it's
done you got to be the real person
sometimes and sometime it's fun like you
know you want to look nice if you being
sexy and you want to put a little you
know a little you know a little trout or
a little choo-choo over your cooter or
whatever if you send in sexuals but what
I'm saying is if you're sending natural
face shots you can't use it all the time
you could do the Hat or something if
it's st. Patty's you know or you know
the glass is like reading a book with
your tits out
yeah or nyquil you know Danny's getting
rest you know but you can't do it
full-time all the time because then it
just seem like something's hiding then
it's fake you having a digital world I'm
gonna stay sting it yeah now unless you
bring a filter over if you're gonna date
someone if you go on for soup or
something you bring a big filter and
hold it in front of your face the whole
time while you eat or set it there then
you're actually living the life yeah
you're not living a lawyer living the
life yeah and your life on the filter
yeah true like a true life I'm a filter
here so and if you're Jewish you can
order the go filter fish that's a little
Jewish joke which is kind of cute
all right the last one of the day from
Christian LaMarche sound like you from
Louisiana shout out to them slaughter
boys it hit us okay stop feel it's all
Brennan
my name's Chris I'm from Bullock Quebec
Ontario Canada
not really but whatever Gang Gang
buzz-buzz I got a question for King it
or stinging circumcisions you down for a
nice clean head or you down for the
foreskin not a snow man
let it snow man we say don't touch me
and you see that no and he hit his
[ __ ] stepmother what I'm saying is
this brother hat look if you're [ __ ]
Weiner okay
if your wiener your body Weiner wants to
look like a little damn Ewok or
something then ya have foreskin you
[ __ ] creep okay it looks like your
Weiner is wearing like a little [ __ ]
dumb hat it looks like it's wearing it's
some sort of hood yeah yeah I heard it I
heard it feels better though really well
God gave us hoods for a reason and then
we went nah [ __ ] it then sniped it so it
looks like a bald net but you know what
else wears a hood Klu Klux Klan that's a
good point
who else does and who else were think
about hoods a little red riding hood
yeah and she who collects guy and
members Ku Klux Klan Isis this [ __ ]
don't end well is what I'm saying guys
lose oh you were dropping knowledge
today don't [ __ ] touch me I've been
[ __ ] Kay's boy like Randy Johnson I'm
[ __ ] whoa killing swans [ __ ] who's
the surgeon wasn't really it was a
pigeon ya know swat a giant Swan doesn't
make sense does it do ya swans are in
the air they're huge
yeah us why he didn't kill a swan he
didn't blow up a swan is a pigeon flying
by bro how is there not a video game
it's Randy Johnson oh aviary why is it
uh Connor yeah duck but Randy Johnson
like this how do I know buddy make that
how it's definitely I should we not make
that yeah and let's see that video of
him killing that pigeon right there and
look at that blue the pigeon up fifteen
years ago today it's like one in twenty
million chance of this happening you
know when you're Randy Johnson dude buy
one in three no it was a swan what was
this lady asking about this guy was
asking about the Hulk was asking about
circumcisions ok so first of all the man
is dressed up like the Hulk
so looks like he wants to circumcise
people right thing yeah
seems like really a guy who's trying to
you know get his life back together and
get things in order there's no word on
the walls so it's a couch
yeah he's shooting pornography videos
and he's definitely it's a Airbnb that
he's running a porn scam in but I'll say
this outside of that he seemed like an
outgoing gregarious young man
I think that's else's doctor yeah it's
gonna be well I there's a connection
there you know I'm saying yeah there's
definitely a connection right here's the
problem why you got a circumcised kids
because the rest of the kids and NICU
clearly have a anteater for a dick I can
get that vibe from you sighs all the way
I don't really think so believe that
either actually you don't give off that
Bob's you can tattoo that says I agree
at least on your face like my sons in
the look like if he's in the locker room
the rest of the kids have the helmet
right if he is the only anteater
you know those lockers ain't nice and if
you have that long when you got to paint
that bang a little bit dark if you're
gonna pull it out in the classroom
that's what I think because if people
see that dark hitter they're like oh
that guy it's a bat wing yeah but if you
pull out that long white [ __ ] yeah
that thing is just eating insects dude
it's not gonna go over well I heard you
have to clean it all the time too yeah
somebody safe to take it in you gotta
clean you have to get like a little a
check oil change already went wrong with
his quip tooth brush is like somebody
say you have to do all these like
specialty little deal special massage
yeah I'm doing that too much somebody in
some kind of [ __ ]
snip it off bro yeah that's the past now
could I see that making a comeback yes I
could
yeah hoods are in I heard people want to
do different stuff and people want to
grow you know grow their dick out and
keep different skin on their body that's
fine
so I'm gonna say so it's King you're
seeing it circumcision I'm saying
stinging man I don't want it just no
don't cut innocent kids dick so you're
saying King it keep it i'ma say stay
well is he she's seeing circumcisions if
you don't want it the hood you're
stinging so no cuz the only reason to do
it is uh obviously because everyone else
has a helmet but the other thing is it's
just a religious tradition it makes no
sense it definitely makes sense to
people's makes odd imagine you have a
long skin on your dick and you know the
lorry hurdle neck Brian you suddenly you
get up victim
a little almond or something in there my
daughter in the blender there you fall
down a little dirt in there and you'd
forget about it just shoot that thing
out
no but you get it in the skin it's gonna
get you're gonna get infection it's I
say stay we just do it for religious
reasons yeah I say just until we need it
people need to hide something small like
a jewels or something if you're still in
jewels yeah keep it man that's a good
idea keep a couple diamonds right around
the edge E or [ __ ] headpiece it's a
kangaroo pouch for your dick yeah but if
not dude I don't think you should be
doing it and also this man is also
wearing a green sub you can't see them
but this guy's man is dressed up with
the Incredible Hulk
so maybe also circumcised your childhood
brother you know and uh and I just say
that because I could need that from
experience dude I'm still doing [ __ ]
that I did when I was a kid you know so
and sometimes always I would change some
of my own ways so close Gus mm-hmm it's
not sad no talking with doing wet on I
know you guys doing well it's Bradley
yeah Bradley Pro you have the worst
bruise Brad Cooper from uh let's Bruce
metal Holt Bruce Wayne's Batman your
riot bro Wow what was the whole guys
name Oh Bruce Bruce banners banner baby
and uh do key phrase god brother I say I
say King now sting this foreskin no keep
them dicks long no get rid of them I say
keep them
you want those a turtleneck I don't care
but if you see one how are you gonna
feel ah okay okay so you likes a little
bit of fear dude yeah it's fear-based I
love that yeah all right Pisan [ __ ]
bro yeah sending a couple 10 incident a
couple pictures of them I agree I
haven't seen one a long time yep your
dress yeah your dick will rip your whip
brother send that sucker in rip your
stick yeah and we're not doing that but
actually if you know if somebody does
have one send us a picture from not
close up but you stretch it out like a
batwing for us no I don't what are you
going to send it from a medical
perspective dude we're not I'm not doing
[ __ ] like that we're gonna get in
trouble yeah you're probably right
don't send them yeah or just all one
that's if you have it draw it or get
somebody to draw it or just describe it
to us in a video yeah maybe that let's
do a couple of descriptions or what it's
like to have uncircumcised penis and
some of the pitfalls of that and some of
joys of that pros and cons yeah well
just entertain you
so we'll do a pro ink on video next week
of of that because I've never even
thought about it before and I think a
lot of dicks
yeah people can tell them if there's a
we need that we need the pros from
someone with the anteater dick
oh yes yes you helmet squad right so we
don't this is only feel that have them
yeah don't submit to us if you you're
just [ __ ] yes and like us I think it'd
be neat to have a couple let's try it
one time pro and con of circumcision of
circumcision yeah and what it's like to
still have that [ __ ] long header you
know I'm saying what it's like to have
that [ __ ] body I like to have that
cape on the free yeah you could just
slurp a puddle up you know yeah yeah but
I'll finish a slush what it's like to
have that wizard sleep you know I'm
saying oh dude that thing definitely
bruh you got that [ __ ] hide and go
sup what's it like to have that thing
let us know is that it evoke praise god
man thank you guys for your submissions
and I'm just tired today man sorry I've
had a long week I know I'm a little bit
tired so I killed her brother you did
great um it took just so it's clear I
get this all the time my DMS not
uncircumcised dick pics I get how they
submit questions and videos the way you
do it is in the link in the YouTube
description box mm-hmm correct
yes and then this week we're gonna have
separate links for rip my drip King
under sting it every every single wine
Oh wonderful there you go so it's in the
link in the description box of the King
and sting YouTube mm-hmm there you go
that's I submit them y'all yep and you
can support King in the sting by
following us on Instagram and you can
support us just like how you guys have
been subscribing yeah fan artwork the
formation so much you guys make the show
we love you guys see this should has
been a blast you can support our
advertisers and sponsors if you want to
if it's something that you need and and
we greatly appreciated man this has been
exciting so far we're still in a
temporary studio some people don't know
that so at some point we'll be moving to
a different studio
but we've been you know really fortunate
to have just a fun team that we're
working with and to be figuring this all
out and have Nick and chin on board to
help us out and even cat and now good
yeah a whole squad me yeah it's been a
unique experience and we didn't know
going to go let's keep it going all
right